aunque avanza la vacunación mundial las
manifestaciones en contra de los
pasaportes sanitarios no dan tregua
miles de personas han protestado en
contra de su implementación en francia
alemania reino unido chipre y las más
recientes en italia aunque en marzo fue
concebido para facilitar los viajes
entre los estados de la unión europea
ahora en algunos países se ha presentado
como un documento obligatorio para
trabajar e ingresar a algunos
establecimientos
en italia se extenderá a todos sus
trabajadores tanto en el ámbito público
como privado con posibilidad de una
suspensión salarial para quienes se
nieguen a aportar este certificado las
multas están entre 600 a 1000 euros de
cumplirse italia se convertiría en el
primer país europeo en hacer obligatorio
el pase verde de kobe 19 para ejercer
actividades económicas el 15 de octubre
habrá finalmente una revolución en
italia no iremos a trabajar
porque tengo pues
el gobierno está obligando a sus
ciudadanos a vacunarse para conseguir
este pasaporte que les permite trabajar
para mí esto es un chantaje criminal y
cobarde por parte de nuestras más altas
instituciones
el certificado digital o en papel de
muestra la aplicación de al menos una
dosis de la vacuna que ha dado negativo
o se ha recuperado recientemente del
virus según cifras de la organización
nuestro mundo en datos el 46 5% de la
población mundial ha recibido al menos
una dosis contra el cob y 19 una
enfermedad que ha cobrado la vida de más
de 4.600.000 personas en todo el mundo